et avec nous pour en parler jean pierre
colombiès retraité de la police vous
êtes également porte parole de l'une
l'inpi l'union des policiers nationaux
indépendants bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur ce plateau sur rt
france bruno bartocetti
également avec nous toujours active vous
êtes le secrétaire rhône sud du syndicat
unité sgp police fo bonsoir merci d'être
également avec nous alors il en fallait
un petit peu de temps pour
dire toutes ces annonces on va aller
essayer de décrypter ensemble on va
écouter encore une fois emmanuel macron
en vente vous faire réagir qui a
multiplié les promesses aujourd'hui
le but est de penser la police et la
gendarmerie de 2030 une police qui doit
faire face aux nouvelles formes de
délinquance qui pullulent dans l'espace
numérique le deal par messagerie crypté
les escroqueries digital la
cybercriminalité une police qui doit se
saisir des technologies numériques pour
aller plus vite enquêter plus
efficacement une police qui doit être
formé équipé en fonction des nouvelles
menaces qui pèsent sur la société le
terrorisme mais aussi la violence
débridée les manifestations sporadiques
l'internationalisation du crime et je
veux nous fixer un horizon
augmenter significativement
c'est à dire doubler sous dix ans
la présence des policiers et gendarmes
sur la voie publique mélangeant bien
colombien s'est effectivement ça en fait
des annonces on va tenter d'y voir clair
déjà ce que vous êtes un policier
heureuse ce soir avec tous ces cadeaux
qui monte en dessus bonsoir mais c'est
surtout la population qui doit être ou
satisfaites ou pas de ce qui est annoncé
mon jeu je crois qu'il faut être un
petit peu sérieux on a eu droit
aujourd'hui un véritable discours de
campagne avec
une sorte de deux récitals à la prévert
de défunts on a tous au cours de ce
discours qui étaient très longs
quasiment interminable pendant plus
d'une heure ou en fait on a une
énumération de dossiers qui sont déjà
très bien connu et bien avant le beauvau
de la sécurité tout ce qui a été évoqué
l'aménagement des horaires la
répartition nouvelles des effectifs sur
le terrain
pour effectivement le reprendre au cours
de cette année par l'émission alors on
n'a pas
globalement globalement je crois qu'il
faut pas être trop naïf on sent bien que
le président a voulu faire plaisir à
tout le monde à la fois aux policiers
qui étaient présents et à la fois à
certains à certaines associations qui
est également avec la même puce de
contrôle de l'action policière et on
voit que cette annonce de cet organisme
nous enfants ne sait pas trop de quoi il
s'agit puisque ni monsieur casta dernier
le président n'a vraiment décrypter en
quoi les consisté ce fameux contrôler
leur contrôle de jpm et concret par la
création d'une institution vraiment
indépendantes ou une sorte de nébuleuse
parlementaire qui viendraient en supra
évaluer l'action de la police c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ça
n'est pas clair du tout on va reparler
dans un second temps de se contrôler
vous bruno bartocetti vous êtes plutôt
séduits par ces mesures annoncées par
emmanuel macron ou alors effet d'annonce
comme semble le penser votre comparse
sur ce plateau ou véritable changement
de fond c'est vrai que ça rappelle on le
précise quelques promesses de campagne
qui date de 2010 est un
où ils vont soit on est forcément séduit
lorsque nous parle à l'horizon
2020 2023 un milliard c'est un million
que le pcci dans le cadre de la loppsi 2
la loi de rénovation
donc forcément on est très attentif à ce
genre d'annoncés sont un rouage ce qui
est important c'est de retenir bien sûr
que
les side-cars aucune que présida
m'apprend aujourd'hui et a tué un cadre
bureau 200 nous sommes deux les
élections présidentielles et c'est à
nous être très vigilant là dessus
évidemment accueilli ces annonces avec
beaucoup d'intérêt comment ça va être
appliquée c'est autre chose mais de
toute façon m autres
seront obligés de moderniser notre notre
police car nous avons aujourd'hui la
nécessité d'évoluer dans ce sens
pourquoi parce que nos policiers on
s'adapte à des difficultés de
fonctionnement à des
fonctionnements drastique et alors que
celle inverse il faut nous donner les
moyens de travailler bien évidemment
pour pouvoir participer j'insiste
là-dessus participer sur sur la sécurité
parce que tout ne doit pas reposer sur
les épaules de la police et de la
justice aboutir de sécurité alors on va
écouter une première réaction politique
aujourd'hui celle du rassemblement
national l'eurodéputé gilbert collard
miracle à six mois des élections
présidentielles macron se rend compte
que les policiers sont mal traités que
les effectifs manque et que la paperasse
administrative les écrase il se fout de
nous jean-pierre colombien vous seriez
aussi sévère
je n'ai peut-être pas paraphraser
maître collard mais
il est pas tout à fait loyer d'une
certaine réalité ça fait effectivement
des années des années que le diagnostic
sur la paupérisation de la police effet
il ya quand même quelques oubliés dans
son discours en l oubliez le mal être
des fonctionnaires de police avec le
phénomène des suicides qui est toujours
prégnant qui est toujours là et là je
n'ai pas entendu sur ce sujet là de la
même manière qu'ils n'évoquent pas
l'état désespérant de l'outil judiciaire
de la justice alors semble-t-il que ça
doit faire là encore l'objet d'un
nouveau débat avec les membres de la
magistrature m'enfin bon il faut arrêter
aussi de prendre les gens pour ce qu'ils
ne sont pas c'est à dire des naïfs le
diagnostic a été posé il existe depuis
longtemps c'est pas mon collègue mon
ex-collègue ce que syndicaliste qui dira
le contraire mais enfin tout était déjà
sur la table tout était déjà dans l'est
dans les bureaux du ministère
je pense que là je vais être assez
sévère je pense que c'est tout
simplement pas dans son adn c'est
l'aspect sécuritaire mais pardon son adn
on l'a bien vu il a nommé très tôt des
ministres de l'intérieur qui de mon
point de vue n'étaient pas à leur place
gérard collomb n'était pas à sa place
christophe castaner on l'a bien vu a été
très contestée et à juste titre pour des
prises de paroles des prises de position
et des attitudes particulièrement en
décalage avec ce qui se passait sur le
terrain et aujourd'hui on a crise gérald
arbola ministre de l'intérieur qui à
l'époque quand même remonter un petit
peu dans l'histoire a fait partie dé
cabinet de nicolas sarkozy qui nous a
quand même déflatés considérablement et
nous a affaiblis avec des réformes de la
procédure qui aujourd'hui encore alourdi
celle ci est jeune on pourrait en parler
effectivement très longuement mais la
nomination aussi d'eric dupond-moretti
pose problème n'a eu de cesse que de
dénoncer l'appareil judiciaire s'est
fait un ennemi quelque part de tout ce
qui pouvait s'opposer à son métier
d'avocat parce que quand j'entends
parler de simplification procédurale
excusez moi de sourire d'avoir un
sourire un peu cynique parce que si
c'est bien quelqu'un s'il ya bien
quelqu'un qui s'y connaît un
ralentissement de la procédure c'est
bien lui donc je ne vois pas comment
tout à coup ces personnages qui avait au
fond d'eux
une vraie volonté plutôt de ne pas faire
pourrait tout à coup être un grand
réformiste de l'institution police
justice qui sont parfaitement
indissociables si on veut réformer
durablement et significativement le
l'institution judiciaire dans son
ensemble bruno bartocetti vous fait
d'accord avec ce diagnostic de
jean-pierre colombiès emmanuel macron
qui n'a pas nécessairement la sécurité
dans son adn et qui on le rappelle un
seul est rendu aujourd'hui sur les
terres d'ailleurs de xavier bertrand qui
lui fait le même reproche et qui sera
peut-être l'un de ses concurrents à la
présidentielle et et on essaye de
rattraper le temps perdu peut-être trop
beau pour être vrai en si peu de temps
alors il est clair que c'est à nous cela
aurait été accueillie avec beaucoup plus
de satisfaction il ya quelques années en
arrière ceci étant et pour rejoindre
simon ex collègues
et il fait bien de le souligner c'est
très important nous avons perdu beaucoup
d'effectifs sous sarkozy nous avons
perdu 13 1700 postes de policiers et
jeunes entre 2004 et 2012 et à partir de
2012 gili a aucune connotation politique
de ma part puisque notre organisation
syndicale ne s'est pas exprimée avant
les élections présidentielles de 2017 et
ne le fera pas avant 2029 positionnons
derrière le candidat donc j'en parle
librement je donne juste quelques dates
à partir de 2012 recrutement a été fait
dans la police mais à cinq ans ça a été
suffisant en a pas rééquilibré le manque
d'effectifs sous mac ronde pour
continuer à recruter et ne perdons pas
de vue une chose essentielle ce qu'il a
fallu renforcer les renseignements
territoriaux la dg ici et c'est vrai que
ça malheureusement d'enlever les
policiers qui sont sur le terrain alors
je ne veux pas être l'avocat de
maquereau en matière d'effectifs mais
sûrement sur le problème des effectifs
on a perdu beaucoup d'effectifs depuis
depuis presque vingt ans il va falloir
des décennies pour les récupérer après
en revanche et je rejoins mon collègue
de là dessus sur la procédure pénale
ça fait très longtemps qu'on tire la
sonnette d'alarmé c'est de plus un pub
lourd pour nous coller de l'enquêteur de
travailler lorsqu'on parle de sécurité
aujourd'hui sur le terrain tout ne doit
pas reposer sur les policiers en tenue
qui vont on va dire occuper le terrain
lorsqu'on veut démarrer réellement en
réseau par exemple si vous permettez de
stupéfiants ce sont des mois et des mois
inquiète si on atteint des résultats en
deux mois on va faire tomber deux
guetteurs et un dealer donc donnant les
moyens aux enquêteurs de travailler je
le dis sous le contrôle de mon collègue
qui était un policier judiciaire je veux
pas donnant les moyens aux enquêteurs de
travailler pour politiquement répondre à
une atteinte sérieuse en matière de
délinquance autour des stupéfiants et
des trafics d'armes voilà ça c'est très
important c'est à dire que tout ne doit
pas reposer sur la présence policière
est nécessaire déjà nous pour qu'on
puisse travailler en sécurité pour
concevoir trois chefs de cette
population qui nous soutient je vous le
dis bien cette population ne soutient je
pense que vous allez venir sur ce thème
là mais on a besoin aussi de donner les
moyens aux enquêteurs de travailler et
cette procédure pénale voilà sans moi
vous savez je vais pas je vais pas faire
le procès du ministre à la justice mais
franchement on est fatigué on peut pas
travailler aujourd'hui dans ces
conditions c'est très lourd de procédure
pénale les avocats de fass démontre nos
dossiers nos procédures sur la forme
parce qu on est on est à l'on dit par
des tâches très lourde en matière de
procédure alors il ya un discours un
petit peu dissonante parmi les réactions
politiques aujourd'hui
celui du porte-parole d'ing françaises
soumises david guiraud propose de
l'écouter
je rappelle que la police a été le
secteur de la société qui a été le plus
choyé dans les discours politiques et
les mesures sous emmanuel macron quand
vous êtes capitaine de police
c'est-à-dire bac + 3 vous gagnez 2400
euros quand vous êtes professeur des
écoles à bac +5 vous entré en fonctions
avec 1400 euros il faut arrêter de dire
que les policiers subissent un
traitement de défaveur ça n'est pas vrai
jean-pierre colombiès vous réagissez
comme ans à ses propos de du porte
parole de la france insoumise finalement
vous n'êtes pas seul mal traités que ça
je lui répondrai simplement que c'est
surtout un des métiers les plus
difficiles à exercer et que ça se paye
point barre et je trouve que ça
mériterait même encore une
revalorisation de certains points d'un
10 mais ça c'est un débat qui nous
amènerait très loin je crois pour
revenir sur ce cas dit emmanuel macron
je crois qu'il faut un peu un peu de
cohérence et d'honnêteté dans ce qu'on
dit dans ce qu'on fait et le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est qu'on en est loin
pourquoi je dis ça c'est tout simplement
parce que dans le livre blanc qui était
portée par sur fauvergue qui a oublié
quelque part d'où il venait il fait la
part belle aux polices municipales et
aux sociétés de sécurité privées et tout
ça n'a qu'un but qu'un objectif c'est de
substituer aux services publics une
sorte de
phare on donne un blanc seing pour ainsi
dire à une forme de justice privée qui
est de mon point de vue complètement
contestable et qui va à l'encontre même
de l'intérêt général pour savoir ce
qu'on veut c'est bien gentil de faire
des discours en disant policier on a
besoin de vous on compte sur vous on
sait que c'est très dur patin couffin
tout ça sauf que dans le même temps mais
vous faites exactement inverse et que
vous défendez les sociétés privées qui
vont se substituer aux forces de police
on nous rabat les oreilles notamment
avec les caméras le problème des caméras
fallait caméra c'est pas un outil pour
empêcher les agressions c'est un outil
de réaction c'est plutôt pour élucider
des agressions qui ont eu lieu mais en
aucun cas ça ne peut remplacer un
policier sur le terrain alors moi je
veux bien qu'on nous annonce la
multiplication des policiers par deux
d'ici quelques années apparemment on l'a
on est un peu dans la fiction dans la
police fiction parce que on en est très
loin puisque ça s'opposent à des règles
budgétaires très strictes qui nous sont
imposées d'ailleurs par l'europe et donc
tout ça ça va nécessiter la mise en
oeuvre de plan de dispositifs financiers
très lourds je ne suis pas certain je
suis même certain du contraire qu'on
arrive à
mettre en place concrètement ses
promesses on est vraiment dans le cadre
des promesses et y croire à qui veut
bien y croire vous parliez tout à
l'heure on aurait eu besoin peut-être
que le président macron s'intéresse
aussi au moral des policiers évoquant
ces suicides hasard du calendrier cette
affaire qui a fait parler aujourd'hui
une enseigne qui a retiré un soutien où
l'on peut voir des slogans comme à 4 qui
n'est rien moins que l'acronyme de all
cops à basterds en traduction les flics
sont des bâtards je voudrais vous faire
écouter avant de vous faire réagir
quand une marque de jus de fruits fait
son beurre sur la haine anti-flic le
parfait mode d'emploi pour détruire des
relations police population
l'une des réactions bruno bartocetti
vous cautionnez justement cette réaction
illustration d'une dérive vous auriez
attendu peut-être des mots d'amour de la
part du président en tout cas voilà un
peu de un peu de réconfort également
oui forcément puisque de sausseau vous
savez le policier aujourd'hui même s'il
est très courageuse il est très
professionnel il est il est fatigué on
va dire justement toutes ces attaques
qui sont faites à l'endroit d'un
policier républicaine vous savez j'ai
assisté bien là dessus nous travaillons
pour bien sûr interpeller les auteurs
une bonne somme victimes et nous sommes
nous même année sécurité il ya une
sécurité mourat légalement il est
évident qu'on attend de nos politiques
du président de la république d'un
premier ministre de ministre quel qu'il
soit on attend 2 2 1 soutiennent
malheureusement on est souvent pris dans
un étau politique quel que soit le
gouvernement on peut faire le chemin sur
quarante ans en arrière on est sûr
d'alizée on est fatigués et on continue
à travailler avec de force ce qui est
intolérable aujourd'hui c'est évidemment
c'est de voir cette marque de jus de
fruit ou la france est soumise
français se disent je leur donne trop
d'importance à des sites à qu'ils font
leur beurre on va dire sur sur sur le
dos des policiers en les ciblant les
agressant c'est vraiment honteux parce
que personne n'est naïf on sait
parvenez-vous à 2015 c'est pas vieux
c'est serré sein la france entière nous
soutenons est ce que les policiers ont
cherché
à changer la population à la table mais
la terre beaucoup de nos politiques que
pascal est elle si cette nature on a
besoin de moyens pour répondre au
service si ceux qui nous soutiennent et
soutenu par la population certainement
pas
les gens dans mon jeu je peux que
confirmer abondé dans ce sens donc
vraiment la police a besoin mais pas se
voir la police 1 j'assiste bien là
dessus la population la population a
besoin de ministres responsables qui met
vraiment en avant qui est vraiment comme
souci mais unique souci l'interrégion
tout simplement et qu'ils cessent de
faire de la police une sorte d'
ajustement de variables justement
lorsque par exemple il ya des conflits
sociaux très importants comme on en a
connu avec le jus des jaunes qu'on cesse
de se servir de la police comme
régulateur social justement aller et
venir jean-pierre colombien c'est bruno
bartocetti et puisque vous parlez de ces
manifestations il ya eu une forme de
réponse à ses présumées violences
policières qui sont souvent en tout cas
mis sur le devant de la scène par vos
détracteurs emmanuel macron qui annonce
donc la création d'une instance à on en
parlait parlementaire de contrôle des
forces de l'ordre l'igpn ne
suffisent-elles pas non mais enfin
c'est presque drôle d'entendre ça faut
savoir quand même que lorsqu'il ya des
dysfonctionnements majeurs je me
rappelle quand même la ferme et dallas
il aurait pu s'en souvenir monsieur
macron il ya une commission denquête
qu'il était nommé le le sénat s'est
penché sur le problème sur le
dysfonctionnement potentiel qui
pouvaient exister lors des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre mais la police ne
fait que ce qu'on lui demande de faire
faut jamais pas de ça de vue puis à ce
qui s'est passé pendant l'épisode qu'on
a appelé dès gilet jaune je regrette
d'ailleurs ce vocable parce que pour moi
ça correspond pas grand chose mais on
s'est quand même rendu compte et on va
voir comment tu es bien souvent sur des
plateaux de télé cette situation aurait
dû être neutralisée bien avant en amont
ça n'aurait jamais dû durer aussi
longtemps avec autant de violence de
part et d'autre avec une stratégie et
une philosophie d'emplois de mai du
maintien d'ordre était complètement
incohérente la technique de la nasse la
technique de contact qui était validée
par le président d'acs rond et qui à ce
point à radicaliser l'opposition
citoyenne police il en est lui-même le
responsable quand il nomme un préfet de
police comme didier lallement qui
n'osent pas qu'ils n'hésitent pas pardon
à se comparer et qui ne renonce pas la
comparaison le général galliffet le
massacreur de la commune là vous vous
dis qu'il ya un vrai problème donc il
faut arrêter aussi de faire croire que
des policiers sont des ans sont presque
des enfants d immature qui seraient à
peu près n'importe quoi sur le terrain
sentiment donc d'être un petit peu
instrumental bronze et bruno bartocetti
le mot de la fin est ce qu'on arrive
déjà à la fin de notre
décryptage en de ces annonces nombreuses
d'emmanuel macron justement ce contrôle
indépendant qui viendrait des
parlementaires vous vous l'avez reçu
comment dans votre syndicat et vous
personnellement tout simplement l'igpn
ne suffisait pas
l'egypte elle suffit largement parce que
j'ai fait n'est pas là pour vous faire
des cadeaux
si on doit contrôler le travail de
l'igpn un mot si on doit contrôler
encore une fois le travail de la police
avec l'organisme supplémentaires on se
retrouve dans un demi le fun vous savez
nous avons rien à cacher parce qu'on est
on se retrouve dans ma vie j'ai plein
nous sommes pas à l'aise même leur taux
n'a rien à se reprocher je vais pas dire
que l'igpn de travail à charge mais on
peut se poser parfois la question quand
on est policier qu'on aime se retrouver
dans la logithèque donc encore une fois
c'est un contrôle d'un contrôle d'un
contrôle vous avez les chipettes vous
avez mis j allais l'inspection général
administratif ça devient lourd pour nous
parce que nous faisons notre travail et
lorsque les chick'n swell qui siégeait
au conseil de discipline
traduit des policiers qui ont fauté
trouve au les sanctions adaptées mais
retenant surtout que dans la grande
majorité des cas les poules ici
travaillent avec beaucoup de
professionnalisme et si vous m'accordez
un petit test assure le maître d'oeuvre
et y ait de l'ordre surtout sachez
retenant que nous avons affaibli des
effectifs chez les crs chez les gens
avaient un ciel et ses récents de la
matière de maintien de l'ordre alors
sont très professionnels au contraire
renforcé par porto la compagnie de
sécurité au travail accor
propreté très cohérent et sachant rendre
justement à la police les valeurs de
l'ordre et qui cale à travers justement
s'il parlait lui de manière très
professionnelle parce que
malheureusement des cas qui sont des
eaux mais aussi notre institution c'est
vraiment regrettable et jean 4 points
bien voulez rajouter un tout petit
morgan complétés le propos sur lequel je
suis parfaitement d'accord sur l'île
j'ai peine quand même pas perdre de vue
une chose c'est que dis-je epn traite
des affaires administratives
certes effectivement mais tout ce qui
est enquête préliminaire ou même de
flagrance ou deux sur commission
rogatoire se fait sous le contrôle des
magistrats déjà donc c'est pas faut pas
croire que dix gp n est une entité
autonome qui ferait un peu ce qu'elle
veut qui enquêterait au moment où le en
fonction du vent du tout d'abord il ya
un contrôle des magistrats faut jamais
l'oublier et d'un fort était aussi le
débat hypocrite merci en tout cas à tous
les deux jean pierre colombier bruno
bartocetti d'avoir été avec nous suite
no 4 ses nombreuses annonces des manuels
mc ren aujourd'hui